The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT Open
Courseware continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT Open Courseware at
ocw.mit.edu.
Hi I'm Jocelyn and today we're
going to go over fall 2009
exam 1, problem 1.
So to begin with, we
always want to
read the whole problem.
So in this one it says uranium
metal can be produced by the
reaction of uranium
tetrafluoride with magnesium
in a sealed reactor heated
to 700 degrees C.
So we know that we're dealing
with a chemical reaction here.
The byproduct is magnesium
fluoride.
To ensure that all the magnesium
is consumed in the
reaction, the reactor is charged
with excess uranium
fluoride, specifically 10% more
than the stoichiometric
requirement of the reactor.
To produce 222 kilograms of
uranium, how much uranium
tetrafluoride must be introduced
into the reactor?
So that's what the question
is asking us.
Then it says we assume complete
conversion of
magnesium, express your
answer in kilograms.
So we know that the question is
asking us for the uranium
tetrafluoride needed to make
222 kilograms of uranium.
Right?
That's the last sentence.
The sentence that's before that,
however, also gives us
very important information.
It tells us that we need
the stoichiometric
equivalent plus 10%.
And that's very important to
keep in mind because, as
you'll see later, that's where a
lot of people got tripped up
on this problem.
So then let's go to the first
two sentences in this problem
and extract the information
given there.
We know that we're dealing
with a chemical reaction.
So when we are dealing with one
of those we always want to
put down the chemical
equation.
So we have uranium tetrafluoride
reacting with
magnesium to give uranium
with a byproduct
of magnesium fluoride.
And it tells us that it that
it's at 700 degrees C.
That's superfluous information
but you can always put
reaction conditions above the
arrow just to keep track.
So now that we have this
equation are we
ready to move on?
No.
Right?
We need to have a mass
conservation.
We need to balance
this equation.
So to determine if this is
balanced or not, we want to
keep track of the amount of
uranium, fluoride and
magnesium on each side
of the equation.
So we have uranium, fluoride
and magnesium.
And then we have on
the product side--
and that's not right.
This is the reactant
side, right?
And over here is the
product side.
So on the reactant side we have
1 uranium, 4 fluoride and
1 magnesium.
On the product side we
have 1 uranium, 2
fluoride and 1 magnesium.
So we see that we have an
imbalance in fluoride.
To fix that we can put a
stoichiometric coefficient in
front of the magnesium fluoride
on the product side
in order to have 4 fluorides.
We put a 2 there.
And we change that to 2.
But we also have to change
the magnesium.
Right?
Now, although we fixed the
problem in the fluoride, we
have an imbalance in
the magnesium.
So to fix that, we put a
stoichiometric coefficient in
front of the magnesium, switch
our accounting down here, and
we see that we now have
conservation of mass.
The two sides are balanced.
So with our balanced equation we
can now move on to what the
question is actually
asking us.
And we know that we have,
we want to make 222
kilograms of uranium.
We then need to figure
out how much uranium
tetrafluoride is needed.
This chemical reaction
gives us mole ratios.
But we are, right now, have
kilograms. So the first thing
we need to do is convert
kilograms to moles.
And we do that using
stoichiometry or unit
conversion.
So the other thing we
need to know is the
molar mas of uranium.
So this is something you can
look up on your periodic
table, online, whatever
resources you have available.
So the molar mass of uranium
is 238 grams per mole.
Now we just do a simple unit
conversion to get the moles
uranium that we want.
So first we need to convert to
grams. That's 1,000 grams. And
then using the molar mass,
we convert to moles.
And because I have grams up
top here I need to put the
molar grams down here in order
to cancel everything out.
And that gives us 933
moles uranium.
OK so we have the number of
moles uranium we want to make.
Now we can use the chemical
equation over here to
determine how much uranium
tetrafluoride we need.
So the chemical equation tells
us that we need a 1:1 ratio of
uranium tetrafluoride.
However this is where we need to
go back to what the problem
was actually asking us.
And remember that we need the
stoichiometric equivalent,
which is given by this
mole ratio, plus 10%.
So the amount of uranium
tetrafluoride we need is the
stoichiometric equivalent plus
10% times that stoichiometric
equivalent.
And that equals 1,026 moles
of uranium tetrafluoride.
So we found the amount of
uranium tetrafluoride we need.
Are we done?
No.
Right?
If we go back to the question
we see that it asks for our
answer expressed in kilograms.
So that's why it's always
important to keep track of what
the question is actually
asking you and to make sure
you've answered that.
So we have uranium tetrafluoride
in moles.
Now we need to convert it to
kilograms. Again we need the
molar mass.
This time of uranium
tetrafluoride.
And it equals--
so we have 1 uranium per
molecule and 4 fluoride.
And again we just look up that
molar mass of fluoride on the
periodic table.
And that equals 314
grams per mole.
So we do our unit conversion
again.
And this is my favorite way of
doing stoichiometry unit
conversions.
You may have another way that
you learned in high
school or later on.
But this way I know that I'm
keeping track of my units and
everything's canceling
out correctly.
So we have 1,026 moles uranium
tetrafluoride.
We use the molar mass
we just determined.
And remember that this is an
industrial scale process, so
we actually care about the
amounts in kilograms. And we
get 322 kilograms uranium
tetrafluoride.
Going back to what the question
was asking us, we
know that we now have
the correct answer.
And we can put a
box around it.
So that on the exam whoever's
grading you knows that that is
your answer.